Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going take a collection of photos
like these, and magically, create a video
where we can fly through these photos. And
we are going to do all this, with a twist.
So, how is this even possible? Especially
that the input is only a handful of photos.
Well, typically, we give
it to a learning algorithm
and ask it to synthesize a photorealistic video
where we fly through the scene as we please.
Of course, that sounds impossible. Especially
that some information is given about the scene,
but this is really not much. And as you see, this
is not impossible at all - through the power of
learning-based techniques, this previous AI is
already capable of pulling off this amazing trick.
And today, I am going to show you
something even more incredible.
Now, did you notice that most of these were shot
during the daytime, and these are all well lit
images. Every single one of them. So, our question
today is, can we perform view synthesis in the
dark? And my initial answer would be a resounding
no. Why? Well, in this case, we not only have to
deal with less detail in the images. It would also
be very difficult to stitch new views together if
we have images like this one. Luckily, we have
a choice. Instead, we can try something else,
and that is, using raw sensor data instead. It
looks like this. We get more detail, but, uh-oh,
now we also have a problem. Do you see the problem
here? Yes, that’s right. In the raw sensor data,
we have more detail, but also, much more
noise that contaminates this data too.
We either have to choose from less detail and
less noise or from more detail more noise. So,
I guess that means that we get no
view synthesis in the dark, right?
Well, don’t despair, not everything is lost yet.
There are image denoising techniques that we can
reach out to. Let’s see if this gets any
better. Hmm! It definitely got a lot better,
but I have to be honest, this is not even close to
the quality we need for view synthesis. This one
denoises a single image. However, yes, finally,
there is an opening here! Remember, in the world
of NERFs, we are not using a single image, we
are using a package of images. A package contains
much more information than just one image,
and hopefully, it can be denoised better. So
this is what the previous method could do,
and now, hold on to your papers, and let’s
look at this new technique, called RAWNerf!
Can it pull this off? Wow! Seemingly, it can.
So, now, can we be greedy and hope that view
synthesis works on this data? Let’s see.
My goodness. It really does! And, we are not done
yet. In fact, we are just starting. It can do even
more! For instance, it can perform tone mapping
on the underlying data to bring out even more
detail from these dark images, and here comes
my favorite. Oh yes. We can also refocus these
images, and these highly sought after depth
of field effects will start to appear. I love
it. And what I love even more is that we can even
play with this in real time to refocus the scene.
This is a very impressive set of features, so
let’s take this out for a spin and marvel
together at 5 amazing examples of what it can do.
Yes, once again, this is extremely noisy.
For instance, can you read this street sign?
Not a chance right? And, what about now?
This looks like magic. I love it. Now let’s start
the view synthesis part, and this looks really
good given the noisy inputs. The previous,
original NERF technique could only produce
this, and this is not some ancient technique.
Nuh-uh. No sir. This is from just 2 years ago,
and today, a couple papers down the line, and
we get this. I can’t believe it. We can even see
the specular highlight moving around around
the badge of the car here. Outstanding.
Two, actually, let’s have a closer look at
specular highlights. Here is a noisy image,
the denoised version, and the view synthesis.
And the specular highlights are once again,
excellent. These are very difficult to capture
because they change a great deal as we move the
camera around, and the photos are spaced out
relatively far from each other. This means a
huge challenge for the learning algorithm, and
as you see, this one passes with flying colors.
Three, thin structures are always a problem.
Look, an otherwise excellent previous technique
had a great deal of trouble with the
fence here, even in a well lit scene. So,
let’s see. Are you kidding me? Doing the same
with a bunch of nighttime photos? There is not
a chance that this will work. So, let’s
see. Look at that! I am out of words.
Or you know what’s even better, let’s be really
picky, and look here instead, these areas are
even more challenging. And even these work
really well. Such improvement in so little time.
Four, as I am a light transport researcher
by trade, I would love to look at it resolve
some more challenging specular highlights. For
instance, you can see how the road reflects the
street lights here and the result looks not
just passable, this looks flat out gorgeous.
Now, talking about gorgeous scenes. Let’s look at
some more of those. Five, putting it all together.
This will be a stress test for the new technique.
Let’s change the viewpoint, refocus the scene,
and play with the exposure at the same time.
That is incredible. What a time to be alive!
And you are saying that it does all this from a
collection of 25 to 200 photos? We can shoot these
in seconds! Now, clearly, not even this technique
is perfect, we can see that this does not match
reality exactly, but going from a set of extremely
noise raw images to this is truly a sight to
behold. The previous, two-year old technique
couldn’t even get close to these results. Bravo!
And, this is an excellent place for
us to apply the First Law Of Papers,
which says research is a process. Do not look
at where we are, look at where we will be two
more papers down the line. So, what do
you think? What will we be able to do
two more papers down the line? And what would you
use this for? Let me know in the comments below!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!